john gand is one two a 3.21 era as he
faces the reds for the 19th time in his
career and it's a one-hour walk to nick
castiano's here's joe ivato this is the
200th game for joey votto against the
saint louis cardinals
swaying and a mess and a strikeout of
otto
here's a eugenio suarez runner goes
throw by kisner
doesn't matter it's straight three
it was a strikeout of suarez so
back-to-back case
he'll take on wade miley who said he did
not throw a bullpen
to prepare for this start just played
catch to keep bullets in the chamber
runners at the corners with one down
nolan arnado
six for 17. four runs batted in four
runs scored
this season against the reds
base head into right one nothing
cardinals
orinato just served it into right field
he drives in his 12th and it's one
nothing saint louis played an inning in
st louis cardinals one reds nothing and
it'll be a one-out singer for india
here's tucker barnhart
on a hop to edmond spins out there the
turn double play
four
six
three off the bat of barnhart
midway through two one nothing cards two
down here is john gand
strike three called right over the
outside corner then eased again with the
cutter to one two three second two
innings complete in st louis and two
ground ball outs lead to jesse winker in
the third inning for the reds as winker
is on an eight-game hitting streak
winker swings and misses he's out on
strikes couldn't hold up on a change up
down and in
dan picks up his third strikeout and
we're going to the bottom of the third
at busch stadium bay set for carlson and
dylan is two for two but one out in the
third for paul goldsmith and a backdoor
cutter called strike three and that was
right on the money and goldsmith did not
like it but that is two very well
executed pitches the hitter arenado it's
a two ball two strike count
cutter popped up suarez giving chase
india comes over he'll take it and the
third out is made so miley cruises
through the heart of the cardinal order
for the second time fourth inning coming
up nick castiano's to lead things off
against gann here in the fourth inning
strike three call the fastball caught
him looking again struck out winker to
end the third and he gets castianos here
in the fourth inning otto is on first
suarez is coming up with one out on the
fourth
edmond oh what a play here out there
to first not in time but tommy edmond an
incredible play diving to his left
he was able to get the force on bottow
at second going 4-6 a sensational diving
play by the cardinals second baseman
runners hit first and second and here's
john gann there's a ground ball rolled
weekly to short suarez fields throws out
dan at first the inning is over we go to
the pit nobody on one out here's tucker
barnhart barnhart grounded into a double
play hit the ball sharply
swinging a miss strikeout number five
for again we climbed the ladder on that
one he's been down down down with the
fastball nobody on two away
ground ball tommy edmond there
can't hit the deck
and the reds go one two three the
cardinals come to bat in the home fifth
dylan carlson has a couple of hits today
ground ball up the middle backhand
pickup into you jump throw in time to
get carlson at first what a play by
india he had a long way to go up the
middle
backhanded that ball did a jump throw on
the shortstop side of second base
and threw on target and plenty of time
to get carlson and a ground ball headed
to the left side backhand pickup by
farmer deep third long throw got him
close play but goldschmidt's out and the
cardinals are down one two three in the
fifth against wade miley here's jesse
winker hitler's in two tries today and
you gotta figure third time through the
order the cardinal starter still out
there this may be your best chance to
get at john gant
a little flare job it's gonna get over
adamant's head
round to first by winker williams on the
pirouette throws in winker finds some
space and gets himself a hit he's now
hit safely in nine straight games now
nick castellanos castellanos hits it
sharply through the left side for a base
hit
that's his first hit of the ball game
and the reds have back to back base
runners for the first time today they're
at the corners now with two down there's
suarez
ground ball
backhanded de young the long throw the
pit by goldsmith no damage done
deep in the hole went to young in the
pick by goldie we played five and a half
in st louis two out walk to tyler o'neal
and kisner digs in over two he's
grounded out to short and grounded to
first
in the air out to deep left it's well
hit at the wall it is off the top of the
wall o'neal will score
kissner to second
and a two-nothing saint louis lead
a double for kisner two nothing
cardinals with two outs in the sixth
inning here's dylan carlson he's two for
three on the afternoon as carlson picks
up another base hit
breaks his back little floater out to
center
and a three-hit day
runners at the corners here's aronado
base hit to right rbi breaking ball back
to the mound they've got two if they can
turn it over and they do
one four three
a comebacker to sal romano and he turns
down the cardinal threat eighth inning
coming up here in st louis dustianos is
batting for the reds with a runner at
first base
hit hard right to arnotto he catches it
on the line for the third out castianos
is out and the reds strand another
runner on we go to the night as gallegos
comes out to open the ninth inning
cardinal fans stand at busch stadium two
outs two nothing cardinals
and a fly ball lifted out to deep left
o'neal back with room he's got it and
the cardinals have taken the first two
in this series
they hold on